hello everyone and welcome to Game six
of the 2018 World Chess Championship
between Magnus Carlsen Fabiana Caruana
the previous five games have been wrong
if you haven't had the opportunity to
check them out I will put a link to all
of the previous five games in the
description below and I would just like
to make a very short announcement as of
today I've been verified as well as a
valued member of the YouTube community
obviously and YouTube has allowed me to
have of official YouTube merchandise so
as you can see in the top left corner it
says merch available link in the
description I have one design already
that you can all check out but I will
get back to that after we check out this
very nice game so that being said let's
the let's see what we have installed and
it's really really an amazing game a lot
of us were wondering will we ever see e4
and the petrov in this roaches
championship match as Caruana has proven
to be a deadly Petroff player and how
will cause and tackle it so yes this
game does feature a petrov and it will
be very exciting but before that we do
have a couple of photos here we have a
very nice photo we can also use it as a
photo challenge who is the woman that
will make the first move for Magnus
Carlsen and as you can see she is
extremely excited to be making the first
move or or perhaps she's just extremely
thirsty but here we have a move of her
or a photo of her actually making the
first move but she does it in a very
peculiar way she didn't go over to cross
inside of the table and then pushed the
pawn forward but rather did it across
the table and it seems like a very
awkward move to do with your hand but
maybe it's just me I don't know seems a
seems a bit off but yeah who is the
woman in the photo best of luck to
everyone also here we have a very nice
photo of Magnus Carlsen not not really a
close-up but almost I thought you might
enjoy it and also here we have a very
nice photo of Caruana
there we have it really really a
masterpiece so like I said all of the
all of the photos your compliments of
Nicky Riga so do
check out all of her other work a link
to her social media will be in the
description below so feel free to check
that out as well
now let's check out the game like we
said cousin has the white pieces and he
opens with E for this time and of course
when we saw before I was very much
obvious that Cora wanna would go for his
petrol of defense we have E 5 Knight to
f3 in the knight to f6 so the petrov is
on the board Knight captures on e5 d 6
kicking the knight back and here are
usually you will see the night going
back to f3 and there's like over 20,000
games played in in international
competition available in the database
but here Carson actually goes Knight to
d3 and there are actually very very few
games played with night two nights to d3
fortunately for Caruana he already
played a game with Knight to d3 1 he
defended against Wesley so in the 2018
Sinquefield Cup this year so not really
that much of a surprise to him and ok
Knight captures on e4 we have Queen to
e2 and now Queen to e7 you only move
available to black perhaps if you're if
you have this position with black in a
blitz game you could try fi which leads
to a quite an interesting position after
after I have 3 yes you do lose a piece
but after Knight to c6 pawn captures the
knight to d4 white has to move the Queen
and after a queen d1 now comes F
captures on e4 you force the white
knights to move back and here are very
interesting to move Knight to f2 is what
White has to play to keep his initiative
if white goes something like Knight to
f4 then his life is gonna get very
complicated because you can surprise him
what is of course expecting Queen h4 and
then you he will walk with g3 but Knight
to f3 immediately with chick and here it
would be a really crazy position where
white either has to start running away
with his King or accepted the knight
which then follows with Queen to h4 and
there is no g4 pawn Jeep on to block the
check so here you would have to move the
King King e2 Queen captures an e on f4
and now with the bishop pair and the
black will castle bring Brooks into the
game it will be a very unpleasant
position for white
but such things are four bullets
hereafter 22:27 is the only good move
we have Knight to f4 in the sinful cup
that we already mentioned Wesley so
played Knight to c3 against Cara wanna
and that game ended in a draw here
Crossan goes for Knight to f4 he wants
to go to for that d5 square to attack
Gowanus Queen Knight to c6 and now comes
Knight to d5 kiwanis queen is under
attack and here we have night the d4
karlsen's queen is also under attack
Knight captures on e7 grabbing the Queen
just really no better move other than
sorry about that other than capturing
the Queen after 94 knife captors on e7
if you try something like moving the
Queen there's really no good square to
move the Queen to if you move the Queen
to d3 then you allow all sorts of nasty
discoveries if you move her to e3 then
Knight captures and c2 I will simply win
you the Queen so here not a good night
captures on e7 Knight captures on e2
Khurana also wraps Carlson's queen
knight back to d5 and now interestingly
knight back to d4 so a lot of Knight
moves here and here
Knights the a3 you want to protect the C
to pawn or you don't want to do it with
the King King d1 and because your other
phone becomes vulnerable and you don't
want to do it with Bishop to d3 as after
Bishop to d3 you can you kind of block
your own mm fat here to development you
can't push the deep one anymore and so
on and so on so here after night the d4
we have Knights to a3 guarding the c2
pawn as the pawn on d6 is pretty much
fixed you don't have to worry about
Bishop capturing the night so here we
have a knight back to e6 you might argue
that okay perhaps instead of this
Knights to it remove you could also try
something like d3 but that that doesn't
work yes White is also attacking the c7
pawn but here after Knight captures on
c2 check King moves Knight captures only
one yes you can capture on c7 with check
and capture the rook on a8 but now black
gets the other rook
well can get to night captures on h1 and
here black is just up too much material
so after 94 night to 83 as we've already
mentioned we have Knights to e6 and now
comes f3 attacking blacks night night
for to c5 and now comes d4 kicking the
night back and now we have Knight to d7
also possible here was c6
but after c6 you get you go into a
series of exchanges and obviously black
was not interested in that for example
capture some 3-5 capture some d5
characters and b6 capture some d6 and
after Bishop to e3 yes you can capture
an a3 and mess up White's pawn structure
but you don't really want to give up the
bishop prepare for no no apparent
advantage here so after d4 Knight to d7
now getting the knight out of here and
now c3 now across and makes room for his
knights to go back into the game via
Knight c2 or 93 and here the e6 Knight
is stuck guarding the c7 one so you do
wanna push the d5 Knight back c6 is
played we have nice play for offering a
trade of nights and not night to be 6 if
the knight is captured in Bishop can
capture on e6 we have Bishop to d3
Carlsen develops his bishop we have D 5
D 5 could also have been used as a nice
square for this night but then
developing the bishop on f8 would be
somewhat troublesome so d5 I'm making
room for the Bishop to be developed and
now Knight to see - it's hard to say if
Caruana was even considering capturing
on a3 because if you start playing
something like king of two to get your
rook into the game capturing on a tree
doesn't promise you all that much after
pawn captures Knight a for going after
the c3 pawn
yes White's pawn structure is crippled
here but still with the bishop repair in
such an open game why should be why
should be alright so after d5 we have
nice to see - getting in right into the
game and also preventing Bishop captures
on a3 Bishop to d6 karana develops the
bishop also putting pressure on the
knight on e4 Knight captures on
virtual captures on e6 and now pink to
have to cross and finally makes room for
his rook to enter the game
we have h5 by Caruana preventing g4 and
also expanding on the King set a bit and
now crossing go does the same age 4
expands a bit on the King side and also
prevents a further expansion by Carwin
on the Kings side and here a corona
decides to go for some active play he
wants to push c5 but still you have to
give further protection to the d5 pawn
so before doing it first Knight to d7
and not immediately but first nights to
e8 going for east 7 we have Knights to
e3 and now comes Knight to e7
now the d5 pawn has extra protection and
also this Knight can now go to g6 and f4
if needed and interestingly this is move
20 and we've already made 15 moves with
the night so if you're just beginning
you know to learn how to play chess
you're just getting into chess
principles there is a principle that
says you should not move the same piece
twice in the opening and here we already
had 15 and Knight moves by move 20 this
is what you can do when you're already
you know fully familiar with the
principles and you know you're fighting
for the World Championship title then
you can just jump around with your
knight
so but otherwise don't g3 taking away
all of these squares from black and we
have c5 now finally Caruana decides to
change the change the character of the
position he makes a pawn move and now
cousin has to react to this of course
you don't want to capture in a lot of
Bishop characters on c5 but you do have
to you to expect corona to capture on
before at some point so you have to be
ready for it
Bishop the c2 preparing for this rook to
come to d1 and make his presence known
across the D file we have castles by
Cara wanna look to d1 and now comes look
F to d8 countering Carlson's rockin D
one night to g2 this Knight is now here
either to come to a4 or to prepare the
development of this Bishop on therefore
perhaps if the bishops are exchanged on
f4 perhaps the night
can come to a for threatened eh5 pawn
maybe we can blacks King side a bit but
who knows it's still far too early to
tell
here Khurana goes pawn captures on d4 we
have con capture son d4 and now Luke
eight to c8 comes into the game which
tempo as it comes to with an attack
against the bishop and see to that is
undefended Bishop to b3 and now comes
Knight to c6 putting pressure against
the d4 pawn we have Bishop to f4 now
offering a trade here and of course
black doesn't want to do it if but
captures Knight captures then you're
putting a lot of pressure on the d5
point you're putting pressure on the
bishop you're putting pressure on the h5
point so black would most likely have to
weaken his King side by playing g6 so
not something you want to do first
Knight to f5 Knight to a5 you go after
Carlson's strong bishop on b3 as it is
an open game you know if you manage to
get rid of the bishops you're going to
have some edge ripped D to C 1 this is a
very interesting move because well first
when you look at this you have a feeling
that the only piece undeveloped from
white is the rook on a once so rook a to
c1 might seem like an automatic but then
black can play
captures on b3 and after pawn captures
you no longer have a look on a1 which
might be very useful but also there is
an interesting comment comment by
Alexander II shook and not the one that
I used the for a quote above the board
but that's also a very nice current
instead a rogue D to c1 was played in
Greece you said it whenever you're
thinking which rook you're gonna play to
a certain square you always pick the
wrong rook but it's only an illusion
because and your opponent will play
differently you know depending on which
route you play and then after you get a
certain position you will say oh if only
I played that rook to c1 and not this
rook to c1 but then your opponent would
have played it differently and this
position would never have been on the
board now but he looked at the Aruba D 2
c1 seems better because now if pawn
captures and it captures then you
already have a rook attacking the a7
point here and then most likely would
force black the trade here and it would
be white who would be controlling the
open C file the only open file on the
board and it would not be all that
simple - for black the contract as there
is this tension between the two bishops
so you know would be perhaps would be
better
so instead butcher of the before not
capturing the point here immediately and
here Bishop to d1 here cross and moves
the bishop as now if you allow Knight
captures then perhaps the pawn can come
to a5 and create like a very solid
structure here so Bishop to d1 and now
we have Knight to c4 and okay the b2
pawn is under attack so across some
defense that he pushes it forward we
have B three nights to a 3 and now rook
captures on c8 rook captures and rook to
c1 offering to trade down even the other
pair of rooks
Knights the b5 now going after that d4
pawn but also the c3 square is now week
in White's camp so nice to see three at
some point will also black will be able
to put pressure against the a two point
as well so rook captures pawn cap Bishop
captures and now comes Knights to e3
now if punky if Bishop captured or if
Knight captures here there's been a very
long game or over six hours Knight
captures and if I would have been played
and as the bishop on before his under
attack you have to move it Bishop to e3
attacking the knight also is the knight
moves to a wrong squared and the a
7-point Falls so after Knight to c6 it's
still playable but you've managed to
push the blacks piece is a very very
much back so after night a3 and 93 we
have Knight to c3 defending the d5 pawn
and now Bishop to c2 as the bishop was
under attack and now Bishop to a3
however a nice move by corona this fixes
the a to pawn here on a light square and
this night will capture it eventually
but here we have Bishop to be eight by
car Michelson
now going after the a 7-point pointed
pond to a6 not allowing it to capture it
and now f4 and here we have brush up to
d7 you still can't capture on a2 because
this night is
still very much needed to defend the d5
pawn so Bishop to d7 and now comes f5
and here everyone felt across and didn't
make some progress here with this f4 to
f f5 move because now it really prevents
black from pushing g6 so if this night
could somehow maybe end up on f4 maybe
it could attack the h5 pawn also put
pressure on g6 but you know it's still
far along the road
Bishop to c6 putting further protection
to the d5 pawn and now Knight captures
on 82 is definitely a possibility
Bishop to d1 and here
Korona interestingly doesn't capture
this immediately if he captured it
immediately then as Carson also attacked
the h5 one Bishop captures an H final
five would be played Bishop to b2 and
now going after the d4 pawn and now
Bishop to a7 defending the d4 pawn and
hour after Knight goes back to c3 I
still a black would really have to prove
his advantage but Khurana finds a nicer
way first Bishop to b2 Knight to e4 with
check is a threat that would open up an
attack from the bishop towards the d4
pawn Crossin captures the h5 pawn and
now we have Knight to e4 checked as
planned King moves to g2 and now Knight
a bunch of characters on d4 so Khurana
gave up the h5 pawn for Carlton's very
strong central d4 pawn rather than going
after the a to pawn bishop to f4
defending d3 night and here we have
Bishop to c5 here that the path is very
clear here if Khurana can get his past
deep on pushing then then things were
are looking very you know tough for
Carlson and here Bishop to f3 Bishop to
f3 is one of her is definitely the best
idea if you try something like nice to
see to not allowing this point to attack
the knight and get it out of the way
then black would actually have a very
nice game after pushing d4 because now
after you bring the bishop to f3 to
prevent this connection here then black
play d3 and after you moved the night
now comes the bishop captures Bishop
captures in here b2 and white simply
doesn't have any move to play here
whatever you play here
you cannot capture as the knight is
defending it if you capture with the
budget captures night then wife can even
black and even just capture after you
move you will get a queen into the game
there's really no good move to make and
whatever move you make that's no good
because there isn't a good move here
then Knight to g5 and again you're
winning there's a double attack against
the the handy f3 Bishop and of course
the d1 queen is a terrible threat of
course if you capture then d1 clean the
bishop is pinned you cannot capture the
Queen and there would be really nothing
to do here you would have to capture
this and then Knight captures on f3
would leave Carlsen down a piece but
still it's a very hard even would
Carson's best defense we have Bishop to
f3 now comes nice to d2 and here there
were a couple of ideas cross and could
have gone for like nice to f1 but it dis
leads to a very passive position for
white for example Knight capture screen
captures and now d4 opens up a
discovered attack towards Carlson's King
and now it's two bishops so Khurana
keeps his bishop pair and Carson has a
bishop in the night
kingi two now comes Bishop to b5 check
King e1 Bishop to b4 check and after the
knight locks Bishop d3 white would have
an extremely hard position to defend
so instead Carlsen goes for a different
approach he decides to give his piece
for three extra pawns
he plays Bishop captures on d5
sacrifices a piece and of course Corwin
accepts Bishop captures on e3 we have
Bishop captures on c6 and now Bishop
captures an f4 Bishop captures on b7
with Bishop to d6 is getting his Bishop
out of the way and now Bishop captures
on a6 so here Carson has his a pawn his
be point and his H pawn the three extra
points we discussed but Caruana is up a
knight so how can you do this
first nights the e4 going at
the g3 porn and here GeForce played by
Carson it's interesting if you try
something like a four to start your the
pushing of the pawn as soon as possible
then black will in fact have time to
grab your g3 pawn now you have to move
the bishop to allow your pawn to move
forward and now after you move the
bishop now nice to h5 will be very nice
threatening Knight f4 to win the bishop
and after you move the king now comes
Bishop to b4 and you will no longer be
able to pull this point anywhere as the
bishop is controlling all of the dark
squares here so in fact you would just
have blundered your Jeep on now so
Carson pushes that we have g4 Bush up to
a3 not allowing any pawns to be pushed
forward and now Bishop to c4 after
Coronas Knight attacks this C 3 Square
and the pawn on a - Carson's plan is to
push b4 and then the bishop will be
defending the a2 upon King f8 there's no
need to rush this so better to get your
King into the game as soon as possible
and now comes g5 we have Knight to c3
and now Coulson doesn't allow d8 you
want to be captured but rather he gives
up the beep on Corona captures it you
don't want to allow this pawn to be
pushed to be five we have Bishop
captures King to f3 cross and wants to
get his King into the game as soon as
possible as well Knight to a4 and now
comes the Bishop to b5 attacking the
knight and the Knights the c5 it's very
interesting if Knight the c3 is possible
to attack to the pawn and the bishop but
what can actually play a four and after
Knight captures pawn captures it white
would be able to draw this because after
a Bishop to c5 preventing the b-pawn
from being pushed white simply goes up
and after the bishop blocks white goes
further up with something like g6 King
g5
we have checked king of six phone
capture skin captures and after King to
g7 h5 now King to g8 and now comes h6
with Bishop to b6 and now King to f6 and
after Bishop - sorry about that
Bishop to d8 check
my throat is a very dry for some reason
King to f5 with King to h7 and now comes
b6 you would give up this pawn black
would have to capture and then now you
would approach the f7 point King would
have to defend it and now g6 you are
good to go I will exchange the pawns and
now you will even you can even make a
little joke here but I can give up a
pawn and even stalemate a bishop and
even do a stalemate here
so after Bishop to b5 Knights the c5 we
have a four and now comes f6 King to g4
also possible was g6 but Crossan was
reluctant to create this as now it
really fixes this pawn structure here
and of course at some point you if the
King makes his way down the board and
you want to push your H pawn and maybe
force black to capture it to be able to
push your Jeep on now but alright black
just plays the bishop to d2 and controls
the h6 square it is very unlikely that
this would happen so sorry about that
King to g4 we have night stay e4 and now
comes King to h5 again g6 we said that
we already mentioned this but we may
just show it it does fixes the pawn
structure on the Kings side but still it
can get very dangerous for example if
black isn't careful and goes something
like this then h5 h6 would win the game
from white after King 2 upon to g7 as I
will not be able to prevent queening
here
so after 94 King to h5 and now comes
Bishop to e1 focusing on the h4 pawn we
have Bishop to d3 and now comes Knight
to d6 getting out of the way controlling
the bishop on d3 and also pressuring the
f5 pawn and here we have a 5 by Carlson
we everyone was following the handy
analysis of the supercomputer says a and
says I said that if g6 here then it's
actually a devaluation would be minus 3
but that's kind of normal since you are
down a piece
so a five cross and decides to give up
da five-point we have bushel captures
and now pawn captures on f6 pawn
captures on f6 and now King to g6
getting the King in into the position we
have Bishop to d8 defending the f6 pawn
this was much needed if you could play
something like King to g8 and prevent
king to h7 then that would be excellent
for black but unfortunately you have to
defend the f6 pawn bishop to d8 and now
comes King to h7 a very important move
because if Carson played h5 it would be
a whole different story then black can
actually go King g8 take away the h7
square from Carlsen and then after h6
you don't want to push 86 this will be
pretty much the topic of the entire
position if you ever put upon 2 H 6 then
black will be able to attack the pawn
and win it at some point
sorry about that I seem to be coming
down with something
Bishop to b1 and 94 Bishop to a 2 9 f3
and then at some point you will be able
to check the White King on the e5 square
I the king will have to move and now you
will just force it backwards the bishop
as well and then finally windy h7 pawn
and this will now of course be winning
you will simply push the white King back
occupy the g5 square with your king and
then the knight will remain over itself
to win the f5 form so Carson of course
doesn't want to do this King to h7 was
played and now comes nice to f7 Bishop
to c4 by Carlsen and now comes Knight to
e5 attacking the bishop we have brush-up
to d5 and now the ship to a5 we have h 5
by Carlsen brush up to d2 and now rush
up the back to a2 we have Knight to f3
and now comes Bishop to d5 and this is
sort of the theme of the position black
would really want to white to push h6 to
put this pawn on a dark square where it
can be attacked but white wants to keep
this upon an f5 point on h5 and the King
will always be able to protect the both
of the points by playing King to g6 and
here we have Knights to d4 if if
something like Knights the e1 then King
to g6 and if the g5 you have to be
careful here if h6 is played then you
can even do something like Knight to d3
h7 and Knight to f4 checkmate but of
course it is very unlikely for that to
happen after Bishop to g5 you will of
course not push h6 you can simply just
move back a king to h7 and then all will
be well
once again so I've progressed up to d5
Knight the d4 and now we have King back
to g6 by Carlsen Bishop to g5 Bishop to
c4 and here everyone in every every
possible livestream was screaming that
this is a blunder and the black is not
winning and a lot of people were trying
to figure out how black was winning and
no one could do it Caruana in this
position play Knight to f3 which was
again characterized as a blunder and
even later at the press conference one
of the one of the news reporters in the
press conference as Carlsen that if he
realized that Bishop to h4 or Caruana
that this was actually winning but I
myself couldn't figure out how this was
winning or why if any of you have like
really exact evaluation and and the
explanation of why this is winning do
share in the comments because they've
shown this position to both cost and
Kohana and the press conference after
and they really had a hard time grasping
that this was actually winning for black
and even after you know playing a couple
of moves that were suggested by the
computer they still didn't seem
convinced that this was actually winning
so of course if you push h6 the wind
does come easy but after something like
Bishop to b5 which is a move across and
immediately asked at the press
conference what happens then
then 92 but still you couldn't you
couldn't get I mean a reasonable
position you're threatening Knight f4 to
window bishop but after King moves or or
Bishop to f3 it will be very hard but
I said if anyone has like an exact
explanation of why this would be winning
for black please do share I couldn't
have figured it out but okay after
Bishop to c4
we have Knight to f3 kinked back to h7
and now Knights to e5 attacking the
bishop Bishop e3 we have nice the g4 and
now Bishop to c4
we have 90 to e3 Bishop to d3 Knight to
g4 and now Bishop to c4 back
Knight to h6 we have pink to g6 King to
e7 Khurana starts making away with his
King into the game as if you repeats 9g
for one more time you will have fallen
for the threefold repetition
Bushra back to b3 we have King to d6
Bishop to c2 and now comes King to e5 so
Khurana doesn't make progress with his
King but we have Bishop to d3 King to f4
Bishop to c2 and now as there is no way
to move the White King from protecting
both of these pawns it's a very little
there's very little black can do here
and Knights the g4 was played Bishop to
b3 if if you go Bishop to d1 and attack
the knight then Knights - III attacks
the bishop and then after Bishop moves
and Knight can capture an F on f5 but
still it would be questionable if you
could actually win this position most
likely there would be a way to do it but
still it would be hard you can go King
g5 because there's still no way to push
at five you the bishop would be hanging
so we would have to go around King g4 to
keep an eye on the bishop but then again
Bishop d1 check he moves you're
controlling the f5 Square it would be if
it would still oppose you much problems
so just instead of Bishop to b3 Knights
to e3 and now h6 finally Corona allows
crossing to push h6 but now it is enough
for him to draw here a bushel captures
on h6 is played and it was in this
position and move ad that the players
agreed to a draw
why did they agree to a draw well now
after King captors on h6 and King
captures on f5 it's a bishop against
tonight and well a knight will not be
able to outmaneuver the bishop to
promote this pawn
one such line we can show
is after the bishop simply moves and
black makes room for the start pushing
his pawn Bishop to b5 we can play f5 but
removes a for now Bishop here the King
comes closer White King also approaches
we have f3 and now Bishop to c6 check
Knight blocks and now King attacks the
pawn we have want to have two but now
simply Bishop to a5 b5 Knight to c3
attacking the better but now simply came
to the g3 you're ignoring the bishop you
just want to grab the f2 pawn King
defense we have Bishop to c4 92 checked
King moves and after Knight g1 you can
either just move the bishop back and
forth or even make a little joke put the
King to f1 and there will be no way to
move you back and then promote to the
pond to a queen as safely so yeah now
after Bishop captures on h6 the players
agree to a draw and Game six now ends in
a draw
now tomorrow we will have a rest today
and then we are continuing with round 7
and Sunday were Carlsen will once again
have the white pieces so yeah definitely
an insane game and really I knew that
well I was presuming that the first time
we will see the petrol we will have all
hell breaking loose across the board but
yeah how did you enjoy this and you know
really if anyone finds like a really
concrete explanation of why Bishop page
4 was winning please do share it I will
should then show it in the next video
but yeah like I mentioned YouTube now
allows me to have a merchandise area in
my channel so you will find a link to it
in the description below it will be the
first thing you will see for now there
is only one the one design and it's
actually this one I've shown it a couple
of months ago I think it's more than six
months if you remember I once did a tall
video where we had this position where a
king in two Queens was on the board and
I called it a chest threesome you really
enjoyed it and then I asked I asked one
person here in my hometown colleague
he's also a designer he works as a bar
bartender I asked him I just told him
what happened and that I wanted any kind
of a design that resembles chess that
includes a a chess threesome and I'm not
gonna you know interfere I just want him
to do it the way he wants to do it the
way he sees it and this this is what he
came up with so in the description job
will be like that t-shirts t-shirts for
men teachers for women like hoodies
there will even be some coffee mugs with
with this design so I do hope you
enjoyed it
I haven't still figure out all of the
features this website offers so I will
look into it deeply but this is just
like a first design perhaps all I'll
even consider making it a limited
edition but we'll definitely see how it
goes sorry I'm definitely coming down
with something I have no idea what is
happening but yeah that's the game I
would like to thank Thomas Croydon
Brunner Cyprian Papa Vizio Christopher
Villa a terrace carpet carpet and Steven
Rhonda for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video CR thank you all for watching and
I will see you soon tomorrow with a
different video aside from the World
Chess Championship and on Sunday we
continue with Game seven of the World
Chess Championship match thank you all
and I will see you soon